what shocking death is set to reshape
the future of the entire marvel
cinematic universe who turns out to be
someone other than who they said they
were multiple times keep watching to
find out
the big reveal in iron man 3 that the
mandarin's true identity was not who it
appeared to be became a polarizing
moment in mcu history love it or hate it
the moment was one most viewers did not
see coming and nearly a decade later
would become a major plot point in a
different mcu film when trailers were
initially released for the third film in
the iron man series fans learned the
mandarin would be joining the franchise
a longtime comic book adversary for iron
man his appearance felt as inevitable as
it was straightforward yet mandarin had
a slippery history when it came to his
racial origins and old comic books and
the casting of oscar winner sir ben
kingsley seemed to indicate for some a
possible whitewashing of the character
that might just make matters worse
ultimately robert downey jr tony stark
discovered the supposed leader of the
ten rings was an actor named trevor
slattery hired to terrorize stark and
the guise of the mandarin a
self-centered coward who saw the
mandarin as just a role he was a smoke
screen for aldrich killian the ultimate
mastermind behind this particular
mandarin terrorist threat while fans
were torn about this reimagining of iron
man's arch nemesis many enjoyed
slattery's antics and a marvel one shot
short depicting his life in prison and
subsequent abduction by the real
mandarin was well received consequently
marvel surprised fans once again a
decade later by making king's lee's
slattery a significant supporting
character in 2021's xiangxi and the
legend of the ten rings continuing his
storyline as a prisoner of the title
character's father the real mandarin
as the mcu came to dominate the box
office throughout the 2010s marvel also
made in-road sphere a mostly separate
but parallel world of tv
releasing series like agents of shield
on broadcast networks and streaming
platforms well shield sometimes reacted
to events in marvel movies or featured
cameos by the likes of samuel l jackson
as nick fury a partnership with netflix
yielded six interrelated series that had
even less to do with the mcu despite not
being closely tied to the movies though
shows like daredevil were well received
but at the beginning of 2019 the netflix
production partnership was dissolved and
all the series were cancelled one of the
casualties was vincent d'onofrio's
portrayal of the classic marvel super
villain kingpin which had earned rave
reviews from fans and critics alike but
it turned out that the folks at marvel
studios were also big fans of dinafrio
because in december 2021 he made a
surprise debut in the mcu proper as a
major figure in the disney plus show
hawkeye that was followed almost
immediately by daredevil star charlie
cox making a cameo as matt murdock in no
way home opening the door for other
discarded netflix heroes to make their
return and cementing those shows as
official mcu cannon
avengers age of ultron may not be the
most warmly regarded mcu outing but it
did offer some unexpected plot points
that would shape the mcu chief among
them was the death of pietro maximoff
brother of wonder aka quicksilver and
scarlet witch who spent most of the
movie battling against the avengers but
ultimately became sympathetic characters
fans are as shocked as hawkeye when
pietro gave his life to save the
avenging archer you didn't see that
coming
[Music]
much like the mandarin this plot line
would be revisited nearly a decade later
much to the surprise of mcu fans as
wonders trauma over pietro's death
became a major plot point in the disney
plus show wonder vision oh and it also
led to the dumbest fake out in mcu
history as evan peters alternate
universe version of pietro turned out to
be just some random guy
come on mcu you can do better
you're
ralph
boner
boner peter quill is essentially an
overgrown adolescent frozen in the
intergalactic fantasies of an 80s kid
who watched too many movies his
obsession with earth pop culture fueled
largely by the mixtapes his mother left
him before her death has him dancing his
way through heights and other adventures
of the guardians of the galaxy and wider
mcu films however when he became caught
up in a galactic battle between xander's
nova corps and roland the accuser in the
original 2014 guardians of the galaxy
most fans were just getting to know the
character and likely expected a final
act fueled by weapons explosions and
superpowers not dance
singing and shimmying in front of the
warlord ronan became so confused that it
allowed the other guardians enough time
to blast ronan and retrieve the power
stone it was a memorable exclamation
point on pratt's now iconic character
and all these years later the guardians
haven't lost their groove
[Music]
pop culture has been telling us for more
than three quarters of a century that
superheroes must keep their identities
hidden the concept even predates
superman stretching back to heroes like
zorro the lone ranger and the scarlet
pimpernell so viewers took it for
granted in 2008 when the original iron
man came out that robert downey jr's
tony stark would do everything in his
power to keep iron man's true identity
on the down low but the movie ended with
stark addressing the world's media at a
press conference distancing his gaze
from the index cards in his hands and
announcing instead with a twinkle in his
eye
i am iron man
it was not only an early signal that the
mcu was willing to take big swings and
diverge from the superhero playbook but
also spoke volumes about the nature of
this cocksure hero stark simply isn't
the alter ego type and in hindsight his
inability to stop himself from taking
credit for iron man was perfectly in
keeping with who he'd become
one of the most harrowing moments in the
mcu occurred when steve rogers best
friend bucky barnes was killed in action
during world war ii in captain america
the first avenger so it turned out to be
a welcome surprise from the title
villain and captain america the winter
soldier was revealed as cap's long-lost
friend steve's astonishment reflected
the feelings of many viewers especially
since the movie was set decades after
steve had last seen bucky the
revelations came fast and furious as
bucky was not only alive and looking
young but also worked for hydra after
being kept cryogenically frozen through
the decades naturally stephen bucky's
previously established friendship helped
goose the rest of the movie making the
pair's climactic confrontation or the
more poignant
nick fury was an integral part of the
plot of spider-man far from home he was
the one who sought peter parker out
while he was visiting europe recruiting
him to team up with quentin beck the
up-and-coming superhero known as
mysterio to stop the elementals
following the collapse of shield fury
was depicted as having being driven into
the shadows but doing his best to
continue to enlist superheroes to
eliminate ongoing threats to the world
so how shocking was it to learn that
nick fury wasn't nick fury at all the
film's post-credits scene brought with
it the revelation that fury may have
been less invested in protecting earth
than the rest of the movie had led fans
to believe it showed fury and his loyal
associate maria hill changing into the
forms of the skrulls talos and soren
their conversation then revealed that
fury had deployed the shape-shifting
aliens to do his job while he pursued
some kind of mission in space with the
rest of the skrulls
everybody back to work
while many of the villains of the mcu
haven't made much of a lasting
impression michael b jordan's take on
eric killmonger in black panther proved
to be one of the exceptions for the
first half of the film the character
seemed to be just an american mercenary
after vibranium but ultimately it was
revealed that he had been playing a long
game patiently waiting for an excuse to
enter wakanda because he was actually
t'challa's cousin and thus had his own
claim to the wakandan throne and more
his father had been killed by t'challa's
father who then abandoned killmonger and
left him behind in america to fend for
himself even though he was willing to
destroy and kill to get what he wanted
killmonger's circumstances and his
desire to carry on his father's mission
to help the oppressed made him
impossibly sympathetic in fact the fate
that awaited him was probably met by as
much disappointment from mcu fans as any
sense of triumphant comeuppance as a
result the character remains one of the
mcu's most potent and memorable villains
it's funny how a seemingly throwaway
scene in 2015's avengers age of ultron
ultimately became the one best
remembered from the film perhaps it's
because the moment was thrilling quite
funny and would later pay off with a
major reward all emblematic of the
unique formula mcu films tap into at the
finest moments during a party at stark
tower early in the film the avengers
jokingly attempted to lift thor's hammer
mjolnir as we all know the ability to
wield the hammer isn't just a simple
matter of strength the individual has to
be worthy to do so with a combination of
heroic qualities that meunier can
magically detect so it came as no
surprise when none of them could lift
the hammer though it did twitch when
captain america tried but later in the
movie it's revealed there's one
character besides thor who can handle
meownia vision after stealing a
synthetic body ultron had created for
himself stark and banner uploaded
stark's loyal ai program jarvis into it
with thor channeling the lightning
necessary to activate the body of course
many of the avengers were suspicious of
this new being they dubbed vision after
all he had at least some of ultron's
consciousness inside him so how could he
possibly be trusted easy answer by
effortlessly lifting thor's hammer
vision immediately proved himself worthy
of their trust and had fans cheering in
the aisles
it seemed inevitable that at least one
or two characters wouldn't make it
through avengers infinity war yet few
could have predicted the movie opening
with a slaughter of at least half of
what remained of asgard and the main
villain of the mcu up until that point
after thor's home was destroyed during
the events of thor ragnarok the citizens
who remained behind sailed into space
only to encounter thanos and his
followers the sequence became even more
shocking when the newly reformed loki
attempted to kill thanos only to be
strangled by the mad titan thankfully
through a mix of time travel and
multiversing an alternate universe loki
would eventually live on in a
self-titled disney plus series but that
didn't lessen the pain of losing the
loki who went through ragnarok in
infinity war
in captain america civil war helmut zemo
went to work employing what he knew
about the avengers to tear them apart
key to his plan was showing tony stark a
video from the night in 1991 when his
parents died in a car crash as it showed
that their deaths happened at the hands
of bucky barnes acting on behalf of
hydra as the winter soldier while
viewers had seen bucky being sent to
carry out the stark's executions earlier
in the film the knowledge he had killed
them was trumped by the heart-pounding
slow-burn sequence where tony learned
the truth viewers captain america and
bucky had all hopes tony wouldn't find
out given it wouldn't do him or the
other avengers any good and it was
gut-wrenching to see cap and iron man
turn on each other their friendship
shattered in a single moment
he's my friend
so was i
when peter parker picked up his crush
liz at her house for the homecoming
dance and spider-man homecoming he was
as shocked as the audience when adrian
toombs the illegal arms dealer he had
been trying to stop was revealed as
liza's father could peter keep his wits
and get out of the situation with his
life secret identity and prom date
intact the moment is magnificently
orchestrated by director john watts who
builds tremendous tension with things as
simple as rear mirror close-ups and the
shades reflected from street lights on
the surface it appears as though parker
still has the advantage as with any
keaton character however this man is no
fool you can see the wheels turning in
his mind as a light of recognition
finally illuminated the deadly
confrontation to come
walk through those doors you forget any
of this happened
and don't you ever
ever
interfere with my business again
peter quill lost his mother to cancer at
a young age and never knew his father
until guardians of the galaxy 2 when he
learned that his father was a celestial
ego the living planet and that peter was
in possession of the same extraordinary
powers as his dad initially ego came
across as a warm parent could have been
missing for most of his life but
eventually his true nature became known
ego revealed that he was responsible for
causing quill's mother's illness and
death something neither quill nor
viewers expected after all ego had
claimed he loved quell's mother yet as
ego himself would point out when you're
a celestial who is millions of years old
and only getting older you don't
experience love like a mere mortal in
ego's mind this may have made his
actions reasonable but for peter it was
the ultimate betrayal
looking back at the breadth of the mcu
there have certainly been plenty of fan
service moments but it's hard to think
of one that garnered more applause and
excitement than the avengers end game
scene when captain america proved
himself worthy remember how cap was able
to budge thor's hammer way back in
avengers age of ultron well by the time
avengers end game arrived the stakes had
become so much higher as the team tried
desperately to restore the half of all
life that thanos had snapped away so
when the trio of thor cap and iron man
confronted thanos with the mad titan
moments from overcoming thor cap's
revelation that he may have been more
worthy than he let on back in ultron
brought joy to both thor and viewers
[Music]
i knew it
the avengers was the first time marvel's
various superheroes teamed up on the big
screen given the excitement of seeing
the team assemble for the first time
fans didn't anticipate the emotional gut
punch of seeing phase one fan favorite
phil coulson ends up on the wrong side
of loki's scepter coulson's death gave
the film real stakes and the uneasy team
of superheroes something to rally around
for fans who loved the steadfast agent
though coulson's demise gave the
avengers extra emotional heft of course
he went on to lead the tv show agents of
shield making coulson not only one of
the first iconic mcu characters to die
but also the first to be resurrected and
more than once
dick fury and shield became major forces
throughout the first many mcu films
throughout that time fans have been led
to believe the organization was a force
for good as did the avengers such clear
lines of good and evil came crashing
down with captain america the winter
soldier however amidst revelations after
decades a parasite had been feeding on
shield from the inside hydra
when captain america and black widow
went to seek answers at the shield
facility they found themselves in an
underground lair there a computer with
hydra scientist arnhem zola's mind
explained hydra's decades of work within
shield an admission that allowed him to
brag while distracting the heroes from
the missiles on their way to destroy the
facility ultimately it took the
destruction of shield to eliminate the
threat from hydra
given all the battles he has fought in
the mcu it's easy to forget that peter
parker is still a teenager so when the
revelation of his identity as a man
behind spider-man compromised the
college acceptances of him and his
friends and spider-man no way home it
made sense that he wouldn't think
through all the possibilities to remedy
the situation and that doctor strange
wouldn't double check that peter had
exhausted every other option before
coming to him for a magical solution to
his problem
unfortunately by the time strange
completed the spell to make the world
forget parker with spider-man things had
gone haywire and the door had been
opened to other universes it would be a
mess that could only be undone with a
very adult decision by the end of the
film peter had worked with strange to
finally make everyone forget about him
it was a choice that left him isolated
alone and clearly entering a new era for
the hero
the third spider-man film in the mcu was
packed with surprises from the web head
teaming up with his counterparts from
the previous spider-man franchises to a
venom series tie-in but one of the most
unexpected moments in no way home turned
out to be much less about the stunt
casting and more about hard-earned
audience affection for an ill-fated
character in every spider-man story
prior to the mcu the death of uncle ben
had always been a catalyst for peter to
become a hero but without a ben in his
origin story the mcu's peter had instead
been in the care of aunt may and had
seemed to discover his fate without a
comparable tragedy until now when may
encourages pizza to help the villains
who have arrived in the mcu from
alternate universes instead of sending
them home to die peter follows her
advice but when green goblin takes
control of norman osborn's body aunt may
pays the price among her final words
with great power there must come great
responsibility
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one